te gusta estar conmigo
que si te gusta estar conmigo
claro que me gusta estar contigo porque
estás preguntando eso nomás oye te gusta
tu trabajo claro que me gusta mi trabajo
desde lo que me gusta mi trabajo oye que
te gusta más
que me gusta más desde luego que estar
contigo y entonces porque no estás
conmigo
pues es que mi trabajo me obliga a
viajar mucho y de alguna manera eso hace
que yo esté contigo
está muy fácil cambia de trabajo
eso me dijo mi hijo diego hace algunos
años cuando trabajaba para una empresa
transnacional como ustedes lo pueden
adivinar al poco tiempo cambia de
trabajo
hace algún tiempo cuando ya empezó este
tema de la pandemia dando unas
conferencias virtuales me di cuenta que
otro de mis hijos eric el más chiquitito
me observaba y llevaba dos horas
viéndome trabajando dando conferencias
en ese momento volteé lo vi de nuevo
elige eric que hace aquí dice nada papi
nada más te estaba viendo te quiere
decir que te amo y venía a darte un beso
otra vez estaba metido inmerso y
disperso completamente absorbido por mi
trabajo
papá ya entendía el mundo esa frase me
la dijo mi hija y tengo tres no creen
que tengo 19 nomás son 3
me lo dijo justamente en una ocasión
hace algunos años cuando me tocó
acompañarla recoger sus calificaciones
al cierre del ciclo escolar en esta
ocasión mi hija había preparado la tarde
anterior una cantidad de recuerditos
escritos de su puño y letra para sus
profesores y maestros y maestras
agradeciéndoles por el enorme trabajo
que habían hecho durante ese año por los
muchos conocimientos y experiencias
fantásticas que habían dejado cuando
terminó de entregar los regalos y
recibir sus calificaciones salimos y le
pregunté eligió y eso fui como que ya
entendiste el mundo en se mira papá es
muy sencillo en todos los exámenes hay
algunos algunas preguntas que son de
opción múltiple es cierto bueno pues ahí
no hay mucho que decidir pero hay otras
en las que queda el criterio del maestro
y entonces yo creo que si además de
esforzarme y prepararme y estudiar
además de eso les caigo bien y soy buena
persona con ellos y les agradezco su
trabajo si tienen duda entre ponerme la
bien o ponerme la mal me la van a poner
bien
pues sí sí sí ya entendiste el mundo
verdad el mundo el mundo el mundo lleno
de problemas el mundo complicado que nos
tocó vivir nada más con las dos grandes
crisis que vivimos en este siglo tenemos
más que suficiente verdad la primera de
ellas la gran depresión en el año de
1929 viene una crisis mundial iniciada
los eeuu que genera una recesión
económica sin precedentes que durante
diez años impacta a los países más
industrializados y a los más pobres la
segunda 90 años después el kobe 19 ya no
saben de qué me refiero verdad pues bien
todos a sus casas todos escondiéndose en
contra del virus las empresas migraron a
lo virtual de la noche a la mañana sin
saber qué hacer verdad en este entorno
tan complicado en este entorno tan
difícil están tratando en este momento
de regresar a un formato de esquema
híbrido para volver al campo de batalla
pues bien en este entorno tan difícil y
tan complicado que nos estamos
enfrentando uno de mis clientes me pidió
que le diera una conferencia sobre cómo
trabajar en equipo y enfrentar una
situación complicada era justo la mitad
del año en ese momento le dijo oye se me
ocurre que demos una conferencia que se
llame el gol de todos en el que entre
todos marquemos ese gol que hace falta
para remontar el marcador y estamos a la
mitad del año entonces hagamos algo como
que estamos en el en el medio tiempo en
ese partido de fútbol y vamos a salir a
la segunda mitad del partido a remontar
ese marcador y me dijo me encanta lo del
gol de todos pero no es así como nos
sentimos
como es entonces me se mira más bien nos
sentimos como que vamos ganando 10 y en
el minuto 90 nos empataron y hay que
jugar otros 30 minutos y ya estamos
exhaustos nosotros ya pensábamos que
íbamos de regreso ya pensábamos que esto
se iba a acabar y que creen que hay que
jugar otros 30 minutos más y ya estamos
cansados eso me da pensar que este en
este caso en particular en este cliente
al que me refiero y en muchísimos casos
más la gente está cansada está viviendo
un entorno en el que los niños están
cansados de tomar este clases de manera
virtual cuántos de ustedes están
cansados de tomar clases de manera
virtual no levanten la mano porque si
muchísima gente en los trabajos tiene 9
10 11 juntas al día
una locura esto ha generado algo que se
conoce a nivel mundial como la fatiga
pandémica el cansancio digital la espera
sin fin y escuche en este nombre por
favor estar amputados emocional mente
así es en modo zombie de acuerdo pues
bien en ese entorno en el que estamos
todos inmiscuidos en este preciso
momento es que se escribe un artículo
muy interesante por harvard business
publishing en enero del 2021 que dice
fundamentalmente cómo liderar a un
equipo cuando el equipo está cansado si
tú también estás cansado es muy difícil
verdad liderar el equipo es muy difícil
llegar a un equipo cansado es más
difícil que dar un equipo cansado cuando
tú también estás cansado es mucho más
difícil pues sí cómo hacer que la gente
pueda salir de nueva cuenta al campo de
batalla
energizado con las pilas puestas cuando
ya está muy cansado el artículo habla de
tres ideas centrales pongan atención
urgente contra importante con pasión y
contención y energizar a todos
diariamente vamos a hablar del primero
de ellos urgente contra importante
tienes que decirle a la gente qué es lo
urgente y qué es lo importante si todo
es urgente nada es urgente sí pero es
importante nada es importante hace poco
tiempo tuve la oportunidad de estar con
jorge ramos en una conferencia en eeuu y
él decía una frase que me encantó y se
la regaló decía de mailing is to keep
the main thing the main thing lo más
importante es que lo más importante sea
lo más importante
qué es lo más importante para ti que es
lo más importante para tu equipo que lo
más importante para tu familia
algunos otros autores han tocado el tema
también jim collins en su libro good to
great dice que si no le puedes definir a
tu equipo tres cosas que sean prioridad
entonces no son prioridad ninguna no
cuando tienes 19 metas no hay prioridad
alguna tienes que elegir 3
para pasan y keller en su libro the one
thing dicen que hay una sola cosa que si
haces bien el resto de las cosas se
vuelven más sencillas de lo que se trata
amigos en este momento es de ayudarle a
tu gente a que elija esa sola cosa a qué
enfoque toda su atención y dejar de
hacer todo aquello que no sea
verdaderamente importante pues bien yo
recomiendo inclusive tener un not to to
list no introduce no en una lista de
cosas por hacer sino una lista de cosas
para no hacer porque en la medida que
dejas de hacer unas cosas te puedes
enfocar en hacer lo verdaderamente
importante es la primera herramienta la
segunda con pasión y contención de lo
que se trata es de tener kind full
leaders no mindfulness there's time full
leaders líderes compasivos amables que
conecten emocionalmente con la gente a
la que la gente verdaderamente le
importe de acuerdo es importantísimo
entender que hoy en día en este contexto
de nosotros hemos pasado por la muerte
de la enfermedad grave de un familiar
a manera de ejemplo les pido que
levanten la mano todos aquellos aquí
presentes que hayan tenido la
desafortunada muerte o la enfermedad
grave de un familiar durante la pandemia
imaginen que esto es igual en su trabajo
en los entornos sociales en los que
ustedes se desenvuelven si tú eres
agresivo con alguien con tal de
recuperar las ventas perdidas o con tal
de recuperar el tiempo perdido es muy
probable que esa persona que tanto
esfuerzo hace se te desmoralices de
inmediato es muy probable que esa
persona se te renuncie y se quede
el problema no es que renuncie y se vaya
el problema es que renuncie y se quede
usualmente las personas que siempre
levantan la mano las que nunca dicen que
no los famosísimos altos potenciales o
los de mejor desempeño son los primeros
en sufrir este terrible síndrome que se
llama el síndrome de 'burn out' con lo
cual simplemente baja la cortina dicen
yo ya acabé ya no me interesa nada ya me
quiero ir de acuerdo pues bien en este
entorno de contagio de contención y
compasión se ha logrado medir
recientemente por diversas instituciones
el grado de afectación que ha tenido
para la humanidad la organización
mundial de la salud el año pasado
levantó un estudio en julio que dijo que
1 de cada 10 personas habían sufrido
depresión ansiedad burnout o algún tipo
de crisis emocional cuantos creen que
sufrieron lo mismo en este año en el
2021 esto fue julio del 2020 una de cada
diez en julio del 2021 eran cuatro de
cada diez
cuatro de cada diez personas mercer
empresa muy importante en términos de
recursos humanos y seguros determinó en
250 compañías aseguradoras que el riesgo
más importante no es el tabaco ya no más
es el estrés de acuerdo en este entorno
tan complicado a los líderes les toca
ser compasivos y contener emocionalmente
a los equipos tienen que ser guardianes
del respeto imagínense en una reunión de
trabajo en el que alguna de las personas
dice a la gente que todavía sigue de
manera virtual y ellos ya están
presencial imagínense una frasecita de
éstas a ver si ya vienes no a veces
etiqueta lo miedoso que te estamos
esperando para lee es para lee el líder
en ese momento tiene que atajar ese
comentario decir perdón cada persona
tiene su circunstancia personal y sus
tiempos
para poder solventar esta situación este
es un tema también de diversidad de
inclusión en el que la gente tiene que
guardar respeto por los miedos los
tiempos los padecimientos y las
circunstancias personales de cada uno de
ellos pero cuál es el problema cuál es
el problema que estamos enfrentando el
problema estamos enfrentando amigos y
amigas es que estamos viviendo
tristemente un fenómeno completamente
diferente en la gran mayoría de los
casos los líderes en lugar de ser kind
for leaders utilizan una técnica a la
que yo denomino la técnica del perro de
rancho saben cómo es la técnica del
perro de rancho cuando te sacan para las
broncas y te guardan para las fiestas
o ya que hay una broca traiga elsa
rodríguez
oye no yo voy por el reconocimiento yo
voy a nombre del equipo verdad en lugar
de ser kind full contigo se vuelven
tremendamente egoístas
hoy en día esos líderes están en peligro
de extinción vamos al tercer elemento
energizar a todos diariamente
alguien tiene alguna duda de que el
miedo hoy es el rey si hay algo que ha
ganado la batalla es el miedo no el
miedo a la vacuna el miedo que tenemos
de salir de convivir de tocarnos de
volver a conectar con nosotros mismos el
rey es el miedo el miedo se alimenta del
tiempo mientras más tiempo dejes que
pase más miedo te da te ha tocado que te
quieres aventar un clavado y un
trampolín o del bosnio donde quieras y
mientras más tiempo pasa más miedo te da
pues bien la fórmula para eliminar el
miedo es la acción hace poco escuché a
juan manuel márquez un boxeador que
peleó cuatro veces contra manny pacquiao
a este cuate le decían el devora
mexicanos imagínense nada más
le preguntaron que cómo le hacía para
quitarse el miedo antes de la pelea y él
decía que es muy sencillo
es muy fácil como como se te quite el
miedo pues cuando me dan el primer gol
paso verdad la acción te quita el miedo
aquello o aquella prueba a la que tanto
teme centrar es en donde yace el tesoro
que tanto anhelas pero tienes que
caminar hacia ella la cueva no va a
venir hacia ti lo que tienes que hacer
como líderes dos cosas cuidar y retar a
tu gente por un lado desde luego
cuidarlos como hemos hablado en el pilar
anterior ser compasivo con tenerlos
emocionalmente pero también retar los
les voy a pedir a todos ustedes que nos
están viendo vídeo ya los que nos están
viendo aquí que hagamos un ejercicio
para que vean que la solución para el
miedo es cuidar y retar pongan atención
cierren todos los ojos en este momento
hagan el caso les va a gustar
y recuerden la primera vez que fueron a
la casa del terror
con quién iban quizá por ahí está un
poco empolvado ese recuerdo
quien iba a su papá su mamá algún
hermano mayor quién era
no importa pero seguramente te dijo algo
así mi amor no te preocupes todo va a
salir bien yo aquí voy a estar contigo
pero sigue avanzando verdad retar y
cuidar al mismo tiempo es la clave
energizar a todos diariamente supone
también que no administre su tiempo
administre su energía y qué cosas le
generan energía a las personas
anteriormente las personas creíamos que
con dinero o con un incremento o una
promoción la gente quedaba motivada y
energizada cierto o no pues bien no es
ni el poder ni el dinero son otras las
cosas que energizan a las personas
arianna huffington en su libro drive
dice que son cuatro cosas el nuevo
significado de la palabra éxito
bienestar o wilding
sabiduría o wisdom
asombro o wonder y dar para los demás o
giving así que si tú en tu compañía no
tienes cómo darles un incremento de
sueldo o una promoción es decir dinero y
poder
vale que les ayudes a que cuiden de sí
mismos bienestar a que vivan
experiencias extraordinarias asombro a
que aprendan nuevas cosas sabiduría pero
sobre todo está demostrado que lo que
más se energiza las personas sin lugar a
dudas es que compartan el propósito de
la compañía que haya algo más grande que
su bono y su sueldo el dar para alguien
más labores altruistas o cualquiera otra
en la que se vive el propósito de la
empresa compártelo con ellos y eso hará
absolutamente toda toda la diferencia
pues bien aquí tiene los tres pilares de
vuelta urgente contra importante
compasión y contención y energizar a
todos diariamente osea que si tú eres de
esa clase de líderes o esas clase de
personas que pensabas que simplemente
llegando a pegar tres gritos o siendo
rudo haciéndose sentir cuando llegan a
la oficina van a conseguir los
resultados que esperan te tengo una mala
noticia
no aquí es como le decían a mafalda aquí
hay de dos sopas la de bolitas y la que
ya se acabó
esa ya se acabó de acuerdo ahora si
quieres que el modelo sea sostenible y
tú en verdad quieres que esto se cumpla
tienes que empezar contigo contigo
contigo contigo contigo contigo tienes
que empezar contigo tienes que empezar
priorizando tu tuvo una cosa tu única
cosa tienes que empezar tú siendo
compasivo contigo mismo acercándote a lo
que te beneficia y alejando te de lo que
te daña tienes que empezar por
determinar qué es tu propósito en esta
vida y por qué te levantas todos los
días para ir a trabajar sin que suene el
despertador tienes que asombrarse un
poco más de las cosas maravillosas que
tienes en la vida como un niñito
hablando del pantalón diciéndote papá
acá estoy pues bien tienes que empezar
contigo mismo no hay otra alternativa
así es que funciona esto
pero como dicen los aviones recuérdenlo
póngase usted la mascarilla y luego
ayude a su acompañante verdad no basta
con que lo hagas para ti tienes que
hacerlo también para los demás si algo
nos ha demostrado esta situación tan
complicada que estamos viviendo es que
la única manera de salir adelante es
hacerlo para nosotros mismos y luego
para los demás ayudarle a las demás
personas a que también salgan adelante
porque la situación no está hecha para
egoístas está hecho para gente que ayuda
a otros a salir adelante
yo digo que la vida es como una paleta
de agua le chupes o no se acaba
la disfrutes o no se acaba la vida es
intensamente o no se acaba y que creen
si se acaba antes pensábamos que en
muchos años más
hoy se ha ido muchísima gente alrededor
de nosotros sí sí se acaba y si se acaba
más te vale que entiendas que en este
momento tan complicado y tan difícil y
tan duro en el que de pronto la vida se
acaba te toca a ti tomar una decisión lo
más importante es que lo más importante
sea lo más importante es cierto pues
bien tú eliges si lo más importante son
las personas que amas o no
tú eliges si ver tu dispositivo en la
pantalla de tu computadora oa los ojos a
la persona que amas tú eliges si vivir
en la gran dispersión o en la gran
conexión a mí mis hijos me hicieron
entender el mundo
yo entre la gran dispersión y la gran
conexión sin duda alguna que hoy elijo
lo segundo así que qué les parece si
dejamos esta charla hasta aquí que tengo
unos cuantos besos que repartir
[Aplausos]